>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Susan K. Siegel: Good afternoon.
I have the privilege of
introducing our very special
and very talented interviewer
for this program.
He's one of the nation's leading
philanthropists, a tireless advocate
of reading and literacy, a great
friend of the Library of Congress,
and the individual most
responsible for ensuring
that there is a National
Book Festival year
after year, David Rubenstein.
[ Applause ]
>> David M. Rubenstein: I know
I couldn't do that so -- .
So we're very privileged today
to have Diane Rehm
as our special guest.
[ Applause ]
So, sounds like everybody
knows who she is
but I'll give a very
brief introduction
and then we'll cover a lot of
her life in the discussion.
But she's a native of the
Washington area, actually graduated
from Roosevelt High School.
She -- other Roosevelt -- and
then she decided to volunteer
for a radio talk show on WAMU
and ultimately she became the
host of that show in 1979.
And subsequently that show, which
was called "The Kaleidoscope"
at the time, was renamed "The Diane
Rehm Show" in 1984 I think it is?
>> Diane Rehm: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
And subsequently it was
made an NPR broadcast
and not just a Washington
broadcast but nationwide.
Diane, in addition to hosting that
show every weekday for now 37 years,
and she will retire from that
show at the end of this year.
[ Laughter ]
She is, in addition to
that, she's an author.
She's written several
books about her life.
And the most recent one which we're
going to talk about is right here.
I will show for my own.
I have read it and it's
thoroughly enjoyable.
I highly recommend it because
it's a very personal story
about being alone after her husband
passed away and their relationship.
And we'll get into that in a moment.
So why don't we start by
saying did you ever think
that you would be a nationwide radio
host and have a show for 37 years
when you started volunteering
in 1973?
>> Diane Rehm: Never
in a million years.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And the
reason you didn't think so is
because you didn't, you weren't
trained as a broadcast person.
In fact, as you mentioned in your
book, you graduated from high school
and your parents did not really
expect, you couldn't afford to go
to college so you went right
into work, is that right?
>> Diane Rehm: As a secretary.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
And your parents thought that
was an appropriate kind of thing
for somebody in that
situation at that time.
>> Diane Rehm: Absolutely.
And thought I would
marry, have children,
and follow a prescriptive Arab life.
My father came here
from Beirut, Lebanon.
My mother came here
from Alexandria, Egypt.
I'm first generation,
full blooded Arab.
And they really expected me
to follow in that pattern.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Now
your parents, your father came
from Beirut, your mother
came from Egypt but she was
from Beirut or Lebanon initially?
>> Diane Rehm: They were both born
in Mersin which was in Turkey.
There was no Syria at the time.
My father's family
then went to Lebanon.
My mother's family went
to Alexandria, Egypt.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And
people may not realize it
but there's obviously
a Christian population
in those countries and was.
And so you're actually, you
were raised in a Greek Orthodox?
>> Diane Rehm: Syrian
Orthodox Church.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Syrian Orthodox Church.
>> Diane Rehm: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So you went
to work at the State Department -- .
>> Diane Rehm: Yes.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Eventually.
And you had a job as
a secretary typist.
>> Diane Rehm: Quite right.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
And so your goal was
to get married and
please your parents?
>> Diane Rehm: Absolutely.
My mother in fact was
dying at the time
and she wanted me to marry an Arab.
And she was lying on the couch in
our living room when I was married.
She died two months later.
And my father died ten months
after that of a broken heart.
I was nineteen.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Your mother
was 40 years old when she died?
>> Diane Rehm: Forty-nine.
>> Daivd M. Rubenstein: Forty-nine.
And she died of cirrhosis.
>> Diane Rehm: She did.
>> David M. Rubenstein: But
she wasn't a drinker so how did
that cirrhosis come about?
>> Diane Rehm: We have no idea.
Absolutely no idea.
She and my father used to have a
single shot of whisky on Christmas
and New Year's and that was it.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So
in a previous book you wrote,
your first book, you wrote about the
very complicated relationship you
had with your mother.
And it was the subject of much
of the book in terms of trying
to free yourself from
some of the memories.
And are you able to talk about
how that was so complicated
and why it kind of propelled you
forward to a career later on?
>> Diane Rehm: You know, in an Arab
household one never asks questions.
As a child one took what one's
parents said and that was it.
There were no questions asked.
There was no, "Why do
I have to do this?"
or "Why can't I do this?"
And the irony, David, is that here I
am all these years later asking all
the questions I want to ask.
[ Laughter ]
>> David M. Rubenstein:
So you pleased your parents
I guess to some extent.
You did get married relatively young
and that marriage lasted
for a few years.
>> Diane Rehm: Two years.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Two years.
And then you decided to later
get married to John Rehm.
>> Diane Rehm: Exactly.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And
he was a well educated lawyer
from Harvard, Columbia Law School.
So did you feel at the time he was
well educated, you had only gone
to high school graduation,
was that a problem
or you didn't think it
would be a challenge or -- ?
>> Diane Rehm: He became my teacher
and that was the relationship.
And he loved it and so did I.
I could have asked him any question
about politics, about history,
about music, about
art, about literature
and he could help me learn.
And that's what he did.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So you
had a fairly traditional marriage
early on.
You had two children.
>> Diane Rehm: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
And you have two children
and they're now grown
and living elsewhere.
>> Diane Rehm: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
And you have grandchildren.
>> Diane Rehm: Yes.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And so
when your children were growing
up you decided to maybe try
to do something else other
than raise your children.
What propelled you to try to
do something else at the time?
>> Diane Rehm: I think it was in
the midst of the feminine revolution
when all of us of my era
began asking ourselves,
"Is there something else?"
My children were at the
time fourteen and eleven
and I thought what's going to
happen to me after they're gone?
They had been my life
for fourteen years.
What's next?
Betty Freidan's book came
out and I thought well,
maybe there is something.
And when the opportunity
to volunteer
at this tiny little station, this is
1973, tiny little station not even
yet a member of NPR because you
had to have five fulltime employees
to become a member of
NPR and we only had two.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
So you volunteered there
and what did you do as a
volunteer, what was your job?
>> Diane Rehm: The first day I
got there as a volunteer I was met
at the door, not by the host,
but by the manager who said,
"I'm so sorry to tell you
but the host is out sick."
[ Laughter ]
And so she said to me, "So I,
the manager, am going to have
to do the program and I'd like you,
Diane Rehm, to come into the studio
and help me do the program."
So the very first day as a
volunteer I was on the air in front
of a microphone for 90 minutes
with a representative
of the Dairy Council.
[ Laughter ]
Ninety minutes, David.
Cream, milk, butter, meat and
I knew from my role as a mother
that the Department of Agriculture
had that food pyramid all wrong.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So did you drink any milk
in that interview or no?
>> Diane Rehm: No.
I drank no milk in that interview.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
So eventually you decided there was
an opening for a fulltime position.
>> Diane Rehm: Indeed.
The young woman who had been
the assistant producer left
to have a baby and I was in the
right place at the right time.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So you
got that job and then the person
who was the host of "Kaleidoscope",
as it was then called,
said she was leaving the job
and you decided you would apply
or were you sure you were
going to apply for her job?
>> Diane Rehm: No.
I was not sure I was going to apply
because at the time I was
doing two part-time jobs.
The Associated Press Radio
Network, I was doing small pieces
on medical issues for them.
And employed part-time by
Physicians Radio Network and getting
up at four o'clock in the morning
to put a microphone in front
of Joe Califano who was at the time
head of HEW, all medical stuff,
the head of the FDA, the head
of whoever was doing
something on medicine.
So two part-time jobs were going
to pay me as much as a fulltime,
five day week, two
hour on the day program
and so I did a plus
and a minus list.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
>> Diane Rehm: A good and a bad.
And finally with my husband we
decided I'd go for the WAMU job.
A hundred other people
across the country applied
for it and I got the job.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And at the
time it was called "Kaleidoscope".
You didn't say let's
change the name?
>> Diane Rehm: No.
Not yet. Not yet.
Not yet.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So to
prepare for those shows you have
to do the research so do you
have people that help you?
Or did you, in the early days,
people that do the research,
book the guests, how
did you do all that?
>> Diane Rehm: David, David, David.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
You did it all yourself?
>> Diane Rehm: In those
early days WAMU had no money,
no resources except to pay for
a few people, the on-air hosts.
I got to the office at 7:30 in the
morning and I was there until 8:30
at night doing the booking,
doing the researching,
doing the preparation,
doing everything.
And at the start it was three hours
of day until November of that year
when "Morning Edition"
came on and then,
thank God, it was two hours a day.
Finally my husband said,
"You can't do this anymore.
You're going to drop dead."
So I finally prevailed upon my then
manager for a part-time assistant.
And eventually it has
reached that point
where we have five fulltime
employees and three part-time.
And I have to tell
you, they're all women.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So have
you ever considered an Affirmative
Action program for your hiring?
[ Laughter ]
>> Diane Rehm: You know, we've
had men as part of the staff.
They've gone on to do
bigger and better things.
I've had people come and go but one
of my producers has been with me
for 22 years, another's
been with me for ten.
You know, it's wonderful.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So
today you've now been doing this
for 37 years.
>> Diane Rehm: Thirty-six.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So of all
the people you've interviewed -- .
>> Diane Rehm: Oh, David.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And
there must be somebody that's --
what was the most embarrassing
thing that ever happened?
>> Diane Rehm: Oh, you knew.
I knew you were going to
you were going to ask.
All right.
Tom Clancy.
And before I even tell
you the Tom Clancy story,
at one point today former Speaker
of the House Newt Gingrich,
with his wife, came over and said
to me, "I want to apologize to you."
I knew exactly why
he was apologizing.
He had promised to be on
my program for a full hour.
And at twenty before
the hour he hung up.
Not because we were
having any disagreements.
He said to me, "I want
to apologize to you.
I left you hanging and you
had to open the phones.
And all these years I've
felt terrible about it
and I want to apologize."
I must be the only
person in the world
who Newt Gingrich has
ever apologized.
[ Applause ]
Really.
So Tom Clancy.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Tom Clancy.
>> Diane Rehm: All right.
Tom Clancy walks in,
he's got dark glasses on.
I think he's going to take them
off when he comes to the studio.
Instead he puts his elbow on the
table, puts his hand up like that,
covering his eyes, he
doesn't even look at me.
I ask him a really good
question, he says, "Yep."
I ask him another really good
question and he says, "Nope."
And I'm looking at the clock.
And I'm thinking I've
got two choices.
I can either say to
him, "Mr. Clancy,
it's clear you'd rather not be here
so you can just leave and I'll talk
to the audience," or maybe
he's got some problem with me.
Maybe he doesn't like me
as many others do or -- .
So instead I'll just open the phones
and let people call
in and talk to him.
First caller, "Mr. Clancy, we love
your books," and Clancy is smiling.
And then the caller goes on to say,
"But you sure are being
arrogant with our Diane."
[ Applause ]
At which point Tom Clancy
takes his glasses off,
throws them on the
table and says, "Oh, no.
We're having a wonderful time.
Aren't we, Diane?"
And the guy on the phone
says, "It sure doesn't sound
that way to us, Mr. Clancy."
And from then on he's a pussycat
and we have a great energy.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So
is it hard to get people,
Presidents of the United
States to come on.
You've interviewed a
number of presidents.
So how do you get them or how hard
is it to book somebody like that
or a Secretary of State
or somebody like that?
>> Diane Rehm: Well, I'll tell you.
When I was honored two years ago
by receiving the Humanities
Presidential Medal I went
to the White House as many people
did this week including NPR's own
Terry Gross who won it this year.
[ Applause ]
Absolutely.
So I went up to the stage to
shake hands with the President
and the first thing he does is to
whisper into my ear, "You know,
Diane, I was on your program
before I became President."
And I whispered back into
his ear, "Yes, Mr. President,
and it's time for you
to come back on again."
And so we are currently in
negotiation with the White House
for me to go into the Oval Office
to do my last program
on the air [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
And we hope that that happens.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Now
since you've just announced that,
it's going to be difficult.
>> Diane Rehm: We hope it happens.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So
when you are an interviewer one
of the most important
things is your voice.
>> Diane Rehm: Yes.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
So when did you realize
that your voice wasn't working as
well as you had wanted it to work?
How many years ago was that?
>> Diane Rehm: It was 1992
when the problem began.
And it began because --
and I can verify this
through Senator Barbara Mikulski --
I started coughing
[coughs] tiny little coughs.
And the cough became more
frequent and it reached a point
where Barbara Mikulski was
coming on to the program
and she was standing there and
I said, "Senator, forgive me."
I was in tears.
I said, "I can't do the interview.
I can't talk."
And she said, "If you need me,
I can help get you into NIH."
She said, "What do you
think the problem is?"
And I said, "Well, I've
been taking a lot of Advil."
And she said to me, and you can
check on this, she said to me,
"You know, that is one
of the reasons we almost
did not approve Advil
for over the counter sales.
But we decided to go
forward with it."
In any case, in order to get a
diagnosis they kept putting tube
after tube after tube
down my throat.
They kept saying to me,
"It's all in your head.
There's nothing wrong with your
throat or your vocal cords."
Finally, and I'm going to tell you
how I sounded the day I got off the
air, [inaudible].
That's how I sounded.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
So you went off the air
and then you began
a search for doctors
who could actually diagnose it?
>> Diane Rehm: Nope.
I had already had that
search from 1992 to 1998
when I finally went off
the air for four months.
And my doctor finally
called and said,
"We're sending her to Johns Hopkins.
We've got to find out if
there's cancer somewhere
or ALS or Parkinson's."
And I got to Johns Hopkins.
I was examined by a neurologist
and an otolaryngologist
and within one hour they said,
"You have spasmodic dysphonia,"
which is a problem whose
origins they have no clue on.
It begins in the vassal
ganglia of the brain.
The vassal ganglia informs the vocal
cords to clamp down inappropriately.
There is no known cause.
There is no known cure.
But there is a treatment
and I received an injection
of Botox that very day.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So Botox
which is, you know, very -- .
>> Diane Rehm: Poison.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Poison.
They gave you a little bit of it
and they told you it would probably
take away your voice for a while.
And did it do that?
>> Diane Rehm: It did indeed.
And for one week I had
absolutely no voice.
I could only whisper.
And my husband had to put his
ear to my mouth to hear me
and he said it was the most
intimate time of our marriage.
[ Laughter ]
>> David M. Rubenstein: So
ultimately the Botox worked.
>> Diane Rehm: Worked.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
And but you still need
to get Botox repeatedly or not?
>> Diane Rehm: Every four
months I fly out to Portland,
Oregon where my doctor from
Johns Hopkins now is and I get
that injection which I just
had two-and-a-half weeks ago.
And then went to Dallas,
fell on the plane,
broke my foot, and
have been at home.
I go back on the air
finally on Monday.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So with a
few months to go you are booking
up people and you are trying
to now get everybody you want
including President Obama.
I assume, given only a
couple of months to go,
you can get almost anybody you want.
[ Laughter ]
So is it the opposite problem in the
sense that you have too many people
who now want to be on and
you can't please them all?
>> Diane Rehm: We receive
about 250 books a week
through which we must do a quick
search as to what makes sense
for the program, what balances the
program in terms of art, literature,
music, history, politics and
that's for the second hour.
First hour is always decided
just 24 hours in advance.
One producer takes charge after we
as a group have all decided what is
the most important program we need
to do tomorrow.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So when you are booking these
people now you have to prepare
by reading the books or
getting summaries of them.
How much research do you have
to do every night to kind
of be ready for the interviews?
>> Diane Rehm: My producers
do 99 percent of it.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So
you are doing this show now
and you've been doing it for a
number of years as I've pointed out.
But you had a relationship
with your husband for 52 years.
>> Diane Rehm: Fifty-four.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Fifty-four years.
>> Diane Rehm: Mm-hmm.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
So what happened
to your husband's health
a few years ago?
>> Diane Rehm: After he
retired from the practice
of international law
he began waiting for me
to come home for a daily walk.
And this was a man, six feet tall,
very strong, very fit, and slender,
and a good strong walk and all of
a sudden I began hearing a shuffle.
And I turned to him
and said, "Sweetheart,
why aren't you picking up your feet?
Why are you shuffling?"
And he said, "I don't know."
Well, then he began having a
series of automobile accidents
and with those the insurance
company said after three accidents
in 18 months we're
cutting out his insurance.
And I said, or John said --
I'm sorry about this noise --
John said, "Well, we'll just
find another insurance company.
And I said, "I think we'd better
have you checked out first."
And it was that series of checks
that finally led us to a neurologist
at Johns Hopkins who said
John had Parkinson's disease.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Okay.
So he had Parkinson's and
he already had retired
and he was doing volunteer work.
>> Diane Rehm: Freer
and Sackler Gallery,
had studied for a year
to become a docent.
Was a docent at Freer and Sackler,
then became a reader for the blind
and dyslexic, and a
volunteer at hospice.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And so
he continued that for a while.
>> Diane Rehm: Yeah.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
But then what happened
when he became too difficult
to medically treat him,
you ultimately had to decide to
put him in an assisted living type
of facility, is that right?
>> Diane Rehm: We decided
that together
after he had fallen one night
at three o'clock in the morning.
And anyone here who has experienced
a person who's fallen knows how
difficult it is to
get that person up.
It took me an hour to get him
just onto his knees and then
to pull him back to
his bed and piece
by piece get his body
back onto that bed.
And we knew then he'd have
to go into assisted living.
So he went into a facility
that you picked out
and you then visited every day
but then you could see the
deterioration in him I guess.
So what was it like -- you lived
together for some 50 years --
what was it like kind
of being alone?
Visiting him every
day, living alone.
>> Diane Rehm: That's
exactly right, David.
That aloneness began when he
was moved to the facility.
And I can remember the very
day walking back into our condo
and realizing, "My
God, for the first time
in my entire life I
am living alone."
I had gone from my parents' home
to marriage, to divorce and living
with a roommate, and then living
with John Rehm for 54 years.
And now to be alone
for the first time
in my life was kind of shocking.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And
then you visited him regularly
but then you can tell that the end
was coming and ultimately he died.
>> Diane Rehm: John said,
"I am ready to die."
John said, "I want my doctors here.
I want Jenny," our
daughter who is a doctor
in Massachusetts, "on the phone.
I want our son here.
And I want you here.
And I want to say to the
doctor I am ready to die.
Will you help me?"
And the doctor said, "In the state
of Maryland I can neither legally,
ethically, nor morally help you die.
The only thing you can do for
yourself is to stop eating,
stop taking medication,
and stop drinking water."
And, as you know, David,
you can go for many, many,
many days without food, even months.
But if you go without water,
the organs begin to break
down very quickly and that's what
happened to John within ten days.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So you have
since become a well known advocate
for the right of people
to decide to die.
>> Diane Rehm: Be careful
of calling me an advocate
if anyone from NPR is listening.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Well,
okay, you're not an advocate
because at one point they said you
weren't supposed to be an advocate.
>> Diane Rehm: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein: You are
a viewer of, you have views on it
but you're not an advocate.
>> Diane Rehm: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
But what are your views?
>> Diane Rehm: My views are,
my views are that I
should have the right
to choose what I want
for my own death.
[ Applause ]
>> Diane Rehm: Thank you.
And I want to say this very plainly.
If you believe strongly that
God should be the only decider,
I support you a thousand percent.
If you believe that you
want every opportunity
that medical science
wants, if you want that,
I support you a thousand percent.
And if you want the right to die
when you believe your time has come,
I support you a thousand percent.
So after I step away from
the microphone in January,
not only am I going to be doing
a weekly podcast, but I am going
to be speaking out around the
country about the right to choose,
to choose for yourself how
you want your life to end.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
Now there are some states
that allow to do that.
>> Diane Rehm: Five.
Oregon became the first.
California, the most recent.
And like the right to marry
the person you choose,
California became the tipping point.
I believe the same is true
with death with dignity.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So you'll be
doing that after you end your show.
Now, in your book you
talk about what it's
like after your husband did
die and you had to adjust
to not only living alone, but
having no partner any longer.
And can you describe what
that feeling was like
and how you have tried to adjust
in dealing with your friends
and reacquainting yourself
with other people
because you now have more time.
But how do you describe
what the phenomenon it is?
>> Diane Rehm: I think the
grief, the feeling of loss,
the yearning for that person
there at breakfast, or at dinner,
or talking about what's
in the newspaper,
I don't think that ever goes away.
I think the idea of closure at least
in my own mind has never existed.
I think the loved ones we
lose are always with us.
And every time I stand at my window
on the fourteenth floor of my condo
and it's windows all
along facing west
and watching the sunset
I think of John.
I believe that I have
expanded my friendships.
I've intensified my relationships
with people and I am realizing
that 54 years that we
had were extraordinary
and precious but life goes on.
And my life does go
on and we shall see.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
So your children live
in different cities now so
they're not living here.
>> Diane Rehm: Right.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
And so therefore you're
grandchildren are not living
here either?
>> Diane Rehm: No.
>> David M. Rubenstein: So have you
decided that you'll, post-January,
you'll put a lot of time
into this advocacy work?
>> Diane Rehm: Indeed.
>> David M. Rubenstein:
And the podcast?
>> Diane Rehm: I already have
three speaking appointments lined
up next year for this kind of work.
And I will be doing
a weekly podcast.
I hope you will all send to WAMU
your own email addresses so that
when the podcast comes out we'll be
able to connect with you right away.
[ Applause ]
>> David M. Rubenstein: So as you
look back on 37 years of doing this,
what would you say is
the highlight of it?
Is it that you had 37 years?
You met so many interesting people?
You have so many people around
the country listen to you?
What has been the greatest pleasure
out of doing this for 37 years?
>> Diane Rehm: The
greatest pleasure, David,
has been the opportunity to
listen, to be in the same room
with all these wonderful guests,
to learn because I think one
of the advantages for
me of not going
to college is that I yearn to learn.
And I have learned every
single day of these 37 years.
What perhaps I would never
have had the opportunity
to do had I simply been lectured to.
I'm not a good person to
sit and be lectured to.
I need to push back a little bit.
>> David M. Rubenstein: Right.
And do your children
give you any advice
about what they thing you should do?
>> Diane Rehm: Ah.
No. They keep saying, "Mom,
you're doing too much."
>> David M. Rubenstein: Well, I
want to thank you on behalf of all
of the listeners who listen
to you for so many years.
I have been one of them and I
was a guest not too long ago.
>> Diane Rehm: Indeed.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And on
behalf of everybody here I want
to thank you but I also
want to give you a gift.
And can the person who
has the gift bring it?
Here it is.
This is your, you just
celebrated your eightieth birthday.
>> Diane Rehm: I did.
>> David M. Rubenstein: And
this is a little birthday gift.
>> Diane Rehm: Oh, David.
Oh, David, that's so dear of you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.